[Music]  mom  what is this  we need more colonies  but that's a lot more work there's  nothing the two of us can't handle  together  [Music]  your life is so retro do you even have a  phone no so how do you talk to your  friends  my mom is my friend  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  what's going on  i'm fine i'm just worried about you i  said i'm fine  who is this woman that's my um  that was all she had  [Applause]  i remember so much  screaming  i didn't want you to know her  why some koreans believe that life's  hardships are caused by the tormented  spirits of their ancestors  amanda are you okay i think there's  something wrong  is this what you want  final resting place  come here  what else have you been lying to me  about  all of this is for you i can't wait to  leave  you're not going  anywhere a must here  [Music]  you